Lawmakers are still working
on a deal to close out
negotiations on a nearly
trillion covid relief package it
would provide more than $300
billion in aid to small
businesses $300 a week
and federal jobless benefits
and the $600 an individual
stimulus checks joining us now
from Capitol Hill the number
three Republican in the Senate
John Barrasso Senator where do
we stand on covid relief talks I
understand there's a lot
of parliamentary rigmarole
but what are the chances that
all sides will sign
on to an agreement today this
gets done today no more delays
we're not leaving until we have
relief for the American people
people are hurting people need
help.
And there are two things we need
to do to right this final
chapter on coronavirus
and the one is to get people
vaccinated we're doing that now
20 million people will be
vaccinated by the end of this
by by New Year's Eve but we need
to provide help for the American
public people who have been
struggling until we get enough
people vaccinated that we can
fully get the economy back
on track and that means people
back to work and kids back
to school.
So direct payment checks
to the American people $600
for people who are watching
if they got a check last time
they will get a check again this
time adults and children
for people who are out of work
through no fault of their own
$300 a week for enhanced
unemployment going into next
year and for the small
businesses and the Working
Families all across America.
We were going to do more
Paycheck Protection loans
for those small businesses can
stay open so people can get
paychecks all the way through
this has been a very successful
program 13,000 small businesses
in Wyoming have used this
program.
It's a little more specific.
This time in that the business
has to be fewer than 300
employees and they actually have
to show a loss.
But that's the way we get this
disease behind us I want to just
hone down on one point
specifically I know that you
worked out the issue about
emergency lending authority
to the Fed but then just after
midnight last night this morning
President Trump said he wanted
to see the direct payments
higher bigger than the $600
to each American who got one
last time I take it you're not
going to go along with changing
that part of the program we need
to get this done today
the president is right in that
this is no fault of the American
people Chris we should have done
this months ago had not Nancy
Pelosi played politics through
the
fall because of the presidential
election she's admitted as much
we've had a bill pretty
comparable to what we're going
to pass today and we've offered
it by Republicans time and time
again the Democrats beat it down
40 different times this has been
wrong the delay has been too
long we need to get it done now
for Christmas after
the electoral college voted this
week to make Joe Biden the next
president of the United States
Senator Mitch McConnell
addressed the issue
on the Senate floor here's what
he said the electoral college
has spoken so today I want
to congratulate President-elect
Joe Biden you were asked that
same day whether or not Joe
Biden is now the
President-elect and you
dismissed it as a Gotcha
question how Senator is it
a Gotcha to ask who is going
to be the president one month
from today well first you know
how the press is sometimes
in the halls of Congress if you
don't give a one word answer
they're not satisfied I talk
to them about the fact that
the Constitution article two
section one and the 12th
Amendment to the Constitution
and I accept what has happened
in the election and with
the electoral college I was one
of over 70% of the people
of Wyoming proud to help
and vote for President Trump
over 70 million Americans have
done that he's done remarkable
things I don't
believe we would have a vaccine
today if it
weren't for President
Trump's determination and all
of those so it didn't turn out
the way I wanted it
to but the electoral college has
now certified the election we
have the Constitution and I
accept the outcome
of the election.
Well so let me ask you directly
will Joe Biden be the next
president of the United States
yes he will you accept that I do
OK that wasn't so hard he wrote
an article for the Wall Street
Journal recently in which you
criticized how Democrats delayed
confirming members of the Trump
cabinet in the month they came
in in January of 2017 I want
to put up on the screen what you
wrote Mr Clinton had 13 out
of 14 in January when he came
in Mr Obama 11 out of 15 Senate
Democrats made sure Mr Trump
only had three Senator are you
going to play the Democrats game
of delay what they did to Donald
Trump
back in 2017 or can you promise
swift confirmation of his
nominees and are there any
of the names you've heard so far
who you consider dead
on arrival.
Well a couple of things.
It looks like the Biden cabinet
would be a third term
of the Obama administration
and that didn't sit really well
in Wyoming we have a role
to advise and consent on these
nominees which is why
the election coming up
in Georgia is so critical
in the control of the Senate why
I want to make sure that Kelly
lefler and David Perdue get
elected there because if you
don't if you want accountability
and not just a rubber stamp
for a Joe Biden cabinet you need
to have people like me
as chairman of the energy
committee so we'll have hearings
ask the tough questions but we
are not going to forget what
happened with President
Trump's administration
and the delayed process that
went through it the so it's not
going to be a Garden party.
If the Republicans are
in the majority these nominees
are going to have to run
the gauntlet in terms
of specific nominees that you
ask about I'm from Wyoming
it's an energy state
here's my concern when regards
to energy Joe Biden has
repeatedly said that
he's against a lot
of exploration for energy a lot
of exporting of energy so his
nominee for the Secretary
of Energy has said this she said
we ought to be doing everything
we possibly can to keep fossil
fuel energy in the ground
the impact of that
on our economy on jobs it is it
cuts the throat of my state
our economy The men and women
who work there the energy that
America needs it's going
to drive up costs significantly
for American families so you bet
I'm going to ask tough
questions.
Finally President Trump says
that he is going to veto
the NDAA the Defense
Authorization Act that funds
the Pentagon funds and Air Force
base in your state of Wyoming
and that includes 26 new
measures that would deal with
cyber defense this of course
and in the wake of this terrible
cyber hack that we've had this
week if the president goes ahead
with his promise and he says
he's going to veto it then it
would have to be this Wednesday
will you vote to override that
veto sir well first I would
discourage him from vetoing I
would encourage him to sign it
especially with this new cyber
hack where we were blindsided
Chris as a nation
six different agencies have been
attacked in our government.
And this has been going on since
March, we need to have
a forceful effective punishing
response.
So people pay a price for this
think twice about doing it again
and one of the things that
the president could do in spite
of his concerns about
the National Defense
Authorization Act is to sign
this let this bill become law
that's what my recommendation is
to the president so he
doesn't face the situation
of a veto override and in 15
seconds will you personally
if he goes ahead and vetoes it
he says he will will you vote
to override sir we need to have
this signed into law
I'm encouraging the president
to do that if it comes
to the House and the Senate
I'm going to be in a position
where I'm going to
have to make that decision I
would be much better
for the country
for the president to sign it
Senator Barrasso thank you.
Thanks for joining us.
Good luck on coming up with that
deal you promised for today
uncovered relief and happy
holidays are going to get it
done Merry Christmas Chris.